Robert Habeck oder wie ich ihn gerade
nenne Robert planlos man bemerkt ja das
Chaos und Wirtschaftsministerium als
Bürger sehr genau ich weiß nicht ob sie
sich auch wundern aber ich frage mich
schon seit längerem was ist eigentlich
aus der gasumlage geworden also bis
heute hat man darüber eigentlich so gar
nichts mehr vom Wirtschaftsminister
Robert Habeck gehört heute wurde dann
bekannt gegeben dass die Zahlung der
gasumlage auf Ende Oktober verschoben
wird der Beginn des Konzepts steht aber
für den ersten Oktober fest dass viel
hinter der Verschiebung ist natürlich
einfach Robert Habeck will sich Zeit
verschaffen läuft es also vielleicht gar
darauf hinaus dass es gar keine
gasumlage geben wird hier verstehen Sie
mich bitte richtig ich fände es
großartig von Robert Habeck wenn er
zugibt dieses Projekt war misst Murks
bleibt Murks ich lasse es fallen aber
anstatt das zu tun zögert Robert Habeck
ist immer weiter hinaus obwohl
offensichtlich ist dass er mit der
Planung überforder